what's been the most helpful resource or
like a creative tool is there a book an
annual event a class that stands out as
like either you continually turn to it
or that was really a turning point aside
from the acting class of course then
write that really sounds like it just
they just believe in you and they it was
really good the films and documentaries
that I've seen from Woody Allen episodes
of taxi the music of artie shaw benny
goodman glenn miller and roy eldridge
red wine and my production team for
neither Ervin and Brooks kephart and
James Lang tyne and my friend drew
Mouser who kept yelling at me to direct
and shut up about complaining and my
wife my wife Isis those were the best
tools that I have and I turn to them
time and time again there's a there's a
two-part documentary on woody allen I
probably watch it three or four times a
month really I searched my I searched my
DVR for old episodes of taxi to get
inspiration I listened to that good old
stuff because it reminds me of my dad
thought was stuff that he dug and little
sensibilities stick with me and my buddy
my great friend unless you meant you who
I write for very much it's a great great
resource she's a wonderful actress and
she's a huge support huge part of my
support system so yeah those those are
the things that I turned to all the time
she reads just about everything I write
and
yeah I just I just keep it moving I'm
always writing since not everybody has a
support system or maybe it's a
well-intentioned support system but it
doesn't work right so where would they
find their own ways to plug into
something they don't want to go out onto
a group they don't want to be sort of
parasitic in that way but then they want
to find what they love how do they know
it's tough man that's tough question how
do you find what you love and how do you
be your own support system I think you
be your own support system by figuring
out what you love I think you find what
you love by opening yourself up and
giving yourself permission to love
whatever you want to love a lot of times
it's hard because people don't really
think they deserve something that's
their own or they feel like other people
need to come first or they feel like
people are depending on them so they
have to be all these other things but
the thing is you're you you're either a
man or a woman and in order for you to
be all these other things you got to
feed that man or that woman first and
you don't necessarily need to know
exactly what it is you just have to
allow yourself the permission to be open
to it who knows what it could be it
could be anything but give yourself
permission to let it come you know and
and when it does come and you feel it
man grab on to it make it your own don't
let anybody tell you you're stupid don't
let anybody tell you you're not supposed
to don't let anybody tell you that's not
how it's done nobody knows what they're
talking about nobody knows what they're
talking about
everybody's trying to figure out how to
do it you know what I mean your way
isn't any better or any worse than
anybody else's it's just yours so just
find your stuff man and love it who
cares as long as you're you do what you
do and you got a smile on your face
Cara's looking by those things who cares
doesn't matter just do what you love
it'll come you allow it to come it'll
come that's what I think anyway yeah
brownies brownies are always good they
help
you